[Musik]
er kommt eine 15-jährige 16-jährige
einfach angeschoben von seiner mutter
ins klassenzimmer rein muss los wurde
herzlich kommen sollen wie die leute
jetzt gesichert bekommen heute vor zwei
tagen habe ich einen hilft mir video
hochgeladen und ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen nach diesem hilft myvideo brauche
ich persönlich erst mal eine pause von
dieser serie deswegen machen wird das
folgende leute wir springen heute quasi
innerhalb von rtl 2 eine serie weiter
und schauen uns heute zum ersten mal
seit sehr langer zeit eine folge von
kraft schule ankas schule kennt ihr
vielleicht ist eine serie ebenfalls 2
fast noch beliebter als hilft mir und
die serie dokumentiert quasi den alltag
von jungen lehrern ist natürlich sehr
realistisch müssen uns nichts vormachen
dokumentiert die klassischen
alltagsprobleme von jungen lehrer von
einem hybrid dessen folgen heißt kein
kleinen der schule ohne marmit die
werden uns heute mal anschauen denn die
ist ja solar davis gescheitert wie immer
gilt wenn ihr einmal rund 51 auf einmal
sind wir schon gewinnen wollt seid immer
unter den ersten 20 kommentare und in
meinem video ganz einfach indem wir die
benachrichtigung an macht wohl nicht gar
nicht lange weiter darum heute wir
starten jetzt
[Musik]
wir starten relativ direkt in dieser
serie rein da kommt eine schätzungsweise
sagen wir 15-jährige 16-jährige also ein
mensch der mittlerweile schon ein zwei
jahre in der pubertät drin als der
eigentlich schon zumindest ein stück
weit im leben klar kommen sollte einfach
angeschoben von seiner mutter ins
klassenzimmer sein okay die mutter
schiebt das geschäftemachen polonaise
die lehrerin sagt ja ich möchte von
allen guten geistern verlassen
elastische probleme von jungen lehrern
in deutschland das wirklich die
mittfünfziger die eltern von den eigenen
schülern einfach mit in die klasse rein
kommen und mitmachen wollen und mit in
der klasse sitzen wollte es ist einfach
absoluter standard in deutschland nur
bei jungen lehrern wohlgemerkt altes
problem nicht ja ich verstehe auch gar
nicht warum sie so eine szene hier
machen ich gehe halt mit der immerhin
unterricht schon seit seit er halt in
der schule seit acht jahren gesagt dass
wir das vollkommen selbstverständlich so
ist ja und so die muss wahrscheinlich
auch die freunde von ihrer tochter erst
mal probe küssen bevor die tochter
selbst ran darf
versiert also der ganze aufbau der serie
richtung als ich nehme an dass die in
dem schwarz weiß gestreiften eine
lehrerin ist ne ist klar tritt auch so
auf als lehrer
ich habe ja auch schon gesagt ich schaue
nach vorn schaut also dies auf jeden
fall leer wer ist jetzt diese tante die
da von hinten angerannt kommt und sagt
ja ich wäre auch gern dabei wer bist du
überhaupt das ganze was wir hier sehen
ist schon ein bisschen kleines bisschen
besser als hilft mir also der
emotionalen schmerz man das hier sieht
ist nicht ganz so groß war selbstständig
nicht bedeuten soll dass es hier in
dieser folge ich auch kompletten unsinn
gibt das kommt schon wieder vor so
klassisches rtl2 syndrom diese videos
wirken einfach wie so ein fiebertraum so
als hätte sich jemand das so auf drogen
ausgedacht oder so im kompletten
delirium
also es gibt zwei lehrerinnen in der
klasse s kommt eine mutter mitte fünfzig
mit ihrer teenager tochter in die klasse
rein ich lasse mir doch hier von den
schülern nicht auf der nase rumtanzen
mir okay okay alles da dann werde es
auch gekehrt scheinbar ist das lehrerin
nummer zwei ja ich hab's einfach
vergessen zu sagen natürlich das ist ja
die sack reis schule dokumentiert ja
realistisch den alltag von jungen
lehrern bei junglehrer das ist so dass
sie halt nur als halber lehrer zählen
bis heute ich meine die kriegen also
halb so viel geld deswegen müssen hat
immer zwei jungen lehrer in der klasse
sein weil sonst wäre ein halber lehrer
so das geht ja nicht sie müssen jetzt
hier den unterricht verlassen sie können
ob gar kein finden wir bleiben
das kommt überhaupt nicht in frage es
kommt gar nicht in frage
ich habe meine tochter noch nie alleine
gelassen bitte was okay schritt für
schritt also diese frau mitte 50 will
uns erzählen beziehungsweise rtl 2 mit
uns erzählen dass das der fall ist dass
diese frau ihrer tochter noch nie
alleine gelassen hat das heißt mal
angenommen die es jetzt so 16 sie ist in
der sie seit zehn jahren jeden tag mit
ihr zusammen zur schule gehören ja macht
sinn schreibe dir noch tests zusammen
oder wir sonst noch nie länger als drei
stunden habe ich die alleine gelassen
entschuldigen sie nachfragen
funktioniert weil es kein problem wird
also ich glaube dass diese person
einfach ihre tochter bis dato noch nie
eine schule geschickt hatte und dann
jetzt als die tochter so 16 wurde hat
sie sich sogar okay es geht so nicht
weiter also ich will wirklich jede
einzelne sekunde des tages meiner
tochter verbringen aber ich glaube die
muss jetzt noch mal die schule jetzt
steht ihr denn so eine schule rein ist
ja ich war schon immer dabei die die
wahlen der schule auf jeden fall kein
problem niemals
das glaube ich nicht es muss ja auch ein
grund für einen wechsel gegeben habe
also schule ist für schöne dort nicht
für eltern und bei uns wird das auf gar
keinen fall nochmal leute warum sind da
zwei lehrer also wirklich was ist das
als ich bei polizisten verstehe ich es
wenn die zu zweit unterwegs sind weil
sie sich gegenseitig absichern so oder
um zeugen zu haben wenn irgendwas
passieren aber warum braucht man zwei
lehrer parallel
ob sie bleiben jetzt eine
unterrichtsstunde aber wirklich nur eine
einzige im anschluss setzen wir uns
zusammen und reden das problem okay ich
habe gegoogelt leute und das stete
wachstum kommt aus dem genre scripted
reality also es ist quasi eine
vorgeschriebene handlung soll aber die
realität darstellen
wie gesagt der alltag junger lehrer in
deutschland also ich weiß wirklich nicht
leute aber mir kann doch keiner erzählen
dass zwei lehrerinnen eine klasse
betreuen das mitten am hellichten tage
ohne dass irgend jemand bescheid weiß
eine frau mitte 50 in polonaise mit
ihrem kind in die klasse rein läuft und
sagt ich bin jetzt auch dabei ich bin
der uhren ich brauch dabei quasi dass
keine einzige person sich in der runde
war fragt sogar zur hölle bin ich hier
gelandet
disziplin ist sowas von wichtig und je
weisheit wird einfach nur gnadenlos
ausgenutzt was soll das denn köpfe
zwischenfrage leute ich will auch nichts
gemein sein okay ich versuche mir der
gedanke demokratischen kräften gelang es
bis hin zu entschärfen warum sehen beide
lehrerinnen so aus als wären sie 20 also
real tag so die linke sieht so aus wie
so 25 und die rechte wieso 19
darüber hinaus den dem hause aus als
wäre irgendwie wollte von rtl 2 inso
eine shisha bar eingangsseite gesagt
jetzt weil japaner com mit dass schule
und du meinst nicht jetzt mal
verständnis für die schule aufbringen
müsste man muss doch noch individuelle
lösung schauen und schüler sind nicht
alle gleich
[Musik]
individuelle lösungen schüler sind nicht
alle gleich das sind die schlagworte für
erziehung im jahre 2019 die lehrer
müssen verständnis dafür haben sie jeder
schüler ist anders wenn ein schüler sich
entscheidet eines tages ein bengalischen
tiger mit den unterricht zu nehmen oder
und sturmgewehr
dann muss der lehrer dass er einfach
respektieren sich jeder schüler ist
anders wir beide kommen wir auf gar
keinen fall auf einen gerade ja ich habe
keine lust meine zeit weiter mit sowas
zu verschwenden der unterricht geht vor
diese hinter gepasst auch so gut alter
also sagen wir das doch keine lehrer die
eine seite
ja ich halte von einem pädagogischen
konzepte und nächsten viel so du
solltest eigentlich hier müssen
konsequenter durchsetzen und nicht
durchgehen lassen dass man mutter mit
dem unterricht kommen und die andere ist
so ganz professionell also sie lebt von
dem was sie hier macht
[Musik]
das ist übrigens auch der name der
schule das ist die cala habibi
gesamtschule
das besondere der schule ist dass die
lehrer sich ausschließt wie gesagt aus
gästen von shisha bars rekrutieren dass
schüler sind ganz normal sagt aber es
sind heftiger
die mutter steht jetzt ab leute das
war's mit dem jungen der iss erledigt
mama holt jetzt einen katharer raus oder
zumindest eine machete
weil wegen individuelle lösungen dürfte
die mutter auch das katana mitnehmen die
schule ist ja klar
was aber auch auffällt ist dass sie
nicht mal zu ihrer tochter hingeschaut
hat sondern so der junge sei hier ein
bisschen so die schule zeigen und die
mutter ist so telepathische connections
sonntag darauf gewartet meine tochter
möchte nicht mit der zeit verbringt
wirklich nett sein wenn du wirklich nett
sein bis dann lässt du meine eva
bisschen in ruhe
ja das ist der punkt wo mama leider in
class gekommen ist weil was hier in der
folge nicht gezeigt werden konnte ist
dass sie danach tatsächlich ihren
landtags ausgepackt hat man muss
wirklich sagen heute auch wenn diese
serie auf den kleinen ticken besser ist
als hilf mir würde ich mich so weit aus
dem fenster lehnen zu sagen dass das
wort reality vielleicht aus dem namen
gestrichen werden sollte
das war so was von diesem kleinen außen
dortigen für euch vorgeschlagen das
video hier um könnte meinen kanal
abonnent würde mich sehr freuen sich
kostenlos für euch und für mich eine
sehr große unterstützung wie sie das in
zwei tagen wieder leute ich die augen
bis dahin